nos dice en la gráfica de igual a
logaritmo en base de tous de x se
muestra a continuación y nos piden que
graphic hemos que es igual a dos veces
el logaritmo en base 2 de menos x menos
tres pausa el vídeo e inténtalo y la
forma de pensar esto es que esta segunda
función que queremos graficar realmente
se basa en esta primera función a través
de una serie de transformaciones así que
te recomiendo que utilices papel
cuadriculado díaz voces como estas
transformaciones afectarán la gráfica
original para obtener lo que necesitamos
bien trabajemos juntos tenemos la
gráfica en morado de ye igual a
logaritmo baste 2 de x
ahora la diferencia entre lo que escribí
en morado y lo que queremos obtener es
en primer lugar no tenemos multiplicado
nuestro logaritmo en base 2 de x por
nada y en nuestro objetivo final
multiplicamos por 2 y en nuestra gráfica
original tenemos el logaritmo en base 2
de x pero en la parte de arriba tenemos
el logaritmo envase 2 de menos x menos 3
de hecho podemos ver esto como menos x +
3 entonces intentaremos cambiar esta
función lo que transformará la gráfica
hasta llegar a nuestro objetivo final lo
primero que debemos hacer es reemplazar
nuestra x con menos x
intentemos graficar que igual el
logaritmo en base 2 de menos x en otros
vídeos hemos hablado de las
transformaciones que ocurren en este
caso pero podemos intuirlo
bueno lo que pasa es que para un cierto
valor de x por ejemplo si x es igual a 4
el logaritmo envase 2 de 4 es igual a 2
ahora ocurrirá lo mismo en el negativo
de 4 porque el logaritmo en base 2 de
menos menos cuatro es igual a logaritmo
más de 2 de 4 que es igual a 2 cuando x
es igual a 1 tenemos que logaritmo más
de 2 de 1 es igual a 0 pero ahora pasará
en menos 1 el negativo de menos 1 es uno
por aquí y logaritmo en base 2 de 1 es
igual a 0
de manera similar cuando x es igual a 8
obtenemos que igual a 3 ahora ocurrirá
lo mismo en x igual a menos 8 obtenemos
el valor de que igual a 3 entonces la
nueva gráfica se va a ver de esta forma
más o menos así
ahora el siguiente paso que debemos
realizar es reemplazar esta x con x + 3
porque esto nos acercará bastante a
nuestra función objetivo al menos en
términos del argumento del logaritmo
ahora pensemos en la gráfica ati que
igual a logaritmo en base 2d y pongamos
paréntesis de la función de arriba solo
para ser claros entonces tenemos que es
igual a logaritmo base 2 de bueno no
sólo de menos x vamos a reemplazar a x
con x + 3 ahora cómo va a cambiar la
gráfica si reemplazamos a x con x + 3 o
podemos ver a x + 3 como x menos menos 3
bueno hemos visto en varios ejemplos
cuando reemplazamos a x x x 3 nuestra
gráfica completa se desplaza 3 unidades
a la izquierda voy a escribir lo
desplaza 3 unidades a la izquierda si
tuviéramos a x menos 3 por aquí
desplazaríamos la gráfica a la derecha
como se verá las gráficas desplazamos 3
a la izquierda bueno el punto donde es
igual a 0
ahora estará 3 a la izquierda lo que
pasaba antes en x igualdad menos 1 ahora
pasará en x igual a menos 4 el punto
donde es igualdad 2 en lugar de pasar en
x igual a menos 4 ahora pasará en x
igual a menos 7 estaremos por acá y el
valor para x donde la gráfica tienda
menos infinito en lugar de pasar en x 0
ahora pasará tres unidades a la
izquierda la gráfica tienda menos
infinito cuánto
x es igual a menos 3 así que podemos
dibujar una recta punteada por aquí y
por lo tanto la gráfica se va a ver de
esta forma
algo así
este es un dibujo a mano por lo tanto no
es perfecto pero que estamos muy cerca
ahora para llegar a nuestro objetivo
tenemos que multiplicar el lado derecho
por 2 ahora queremos graficar que es
igual a dos veces el logaritmo en base 2
de menos x + 3 en paréntesis que es
exactamente lo que nos piden sobre lo
que factor izamos el negativo para
ayudarnos con nuestras transformaciones
ahora esto significa que cualquier valor
que teníamos antes para una x dada ahora
será el doble de ese valor y donde
teníamos el valor de 0 bueno seguiremos
en ese mismo valor pero donde teníamos
el valor de 2 ahora tendremos el valor
de 4 y por lo tanto la gráfica se va a
ver muy parecida a lo que estamos
dibujando ahora
y lo hemos logrado este es el esposo de
nuestra gráfica y es igual a dos veces
el logaritmo en base todos de menos x
menos tres
una vez más si estás trabajando en khan
academy debes buscar una opción que se
vea de esta forma y espero que las
elecciones